ah Greg what's the next story is when I
like a lot Dana
in the NFL in the AFC East tempo C's
favorite former Patriot Danny Amendola
hmm was suplex last week by Bears
linebacker Leonard Floyd in it in a
pretty key play which was called a
penalty extended to drive that the
Dolphins ended up scoring on the Bears
linebacker just picked up the diminutive
wide receiver and just suplex them
backwards as if it was like the WWE or
something it was an angry move but I
don't blame the linebacker cuz that's
how mad I get whenever I see Brock
Osweiler throw a pass you know I mean
that gets just like you just want to
hurt somebody and I like seeing suplexes
brought back into the game like what
would your dragged up to the set to you
use well Erica would you finishing moves
be mmm got a couple all right well I've
when you said this I suddenly I have you
know I have a terrible memory but
whenever you bring up whenever you're
like what would your finishing move
being I'm like oh that's the interesting
thing to do and then I come in and I
think of what my finishing move would be
and you're like I don't know I didn't
really think about it but it was your
idea from the start I'm not saying I
wouldn't think I'm saying I usually
can't remember anything about my
childhood but this question that you
posed to be made me remember what I did
have a finishing move as a kid and it
was called the stapler and it was if you
get me in a position where I can like
get behind you you know I'm not a big
guy maybe grab your arms a little bit
and then just dig my chin into your back
that's called the stapler and that was
my move because like you only have so
many moves as a guy my size I think
that's technically child molestation the
stapler sounds like all it's got all the
earmarks you would wrestle as a young
man like you would end up like wrestling
your friends eat
but not not with the express purpose of
getting my chin into their back I mean
that wasn't the plan that's never the
plan going in but I'm gonna sign that to
you what did you come up with that no I
came up with that be like all right here
comes the stick that's so that's what
you would do if you were playing
football and you like tackled a guy and
you were mad at him you would give him
the staple I was thinking more wrestling
when you said finishing move then then
football Erica what would your finishing
move be um probably checking for moles
check
from moles so ii just take this whole
uniform off and checking for moles
better hope their wife that's that's
agree that's a good one
it's better than Gregg's for sure how
about like you just kind of like grab
you know the opponent's hands but like
their palms and like tickle them for a
little to confuse them and then just
like Neum in the groin does that confuse
you and summer tickles if you were on a
football field and that why not just
need them in the groin if you're gonna
end with the knee to the groin just do
like that I'll tell you what I would do
I've got I've got one of two that I
liked I would pick them up by like their
feet you know I mean like one on the
ground picking by the ankles and swing
them around into the goal posts
especially if you're at the 50-yard line
you'd have to get 50 yards swing really
wind up when you just keep spinning
until you got there and then slam them
into the goalpost or just a classic
throat rip rip there throw it out of
their head that's all good finishing
moves from everybody I think my favorite
part of this whole segment was that when
Greg said Erica what are your finishing
moves she thought he meant sexual Greg
what's her next toy this one this one's
near and dear to my heart last week in
the Texans Bills game Buffalo Bills
running back Chris Ivory was pulled down
from behind by his dreadlock Jadeveon
Clowney the Texans defensive end just
reached out grabbed a big chunk of his
pocket like three feet ya know it's just
one dreadlock yeah but it was like he
has really long dreadlocks and grabbed
him to the ground it looked like the
most meaningful thing ever slam him
straight to the ground in the NFL this
is legal if you have long hair it's part
of your uniform you can take somebody
down like that Troy Polamalu would get
dragged down by his hair sometimes and
whenever players get dragged down by the
hair they never care they're always like
whatever I don't care I'm not mad they
can do that it's not gonna bother me it
is my somehow it's my single biggest
fear even though I don't play football
and I don't have dreadlocks but the idea
of someone pulling me down from behind
ball and running full-speed by one of my
dreadlocks is is horrifying to me much
like my fear my irrational fear of being
eaten by a shark in a swimming pool
where they don't live do you guys have
irrational fears you love sharks - I
love them but in the pool I get scared
I'd love to see you with dreadlocks
that's one irrational
here I would be dope like when Vanilla
Ice kind of went one with the dreadlocks
I was like I could pull that off
whenever I pull out of my like parking
spot on the street every day to take a
left
I basically imagine myself getting
slammed by another car every single time
I don't know if that's irrational or not
and I just feel like eventually it's
gonna happen even though I check for it
so I does it I don't know if that counts
I mean it council that's like a real
fear that I should have especially if
you're a parent or even a halfway decent
one like Gregor's I should have an
irrational fear Ericka an irrational
fears besides dying alone I have like
afraid I'm afraid of impulses so like if
there was like if I was in a barber shop
like I'm afraid that like I might like
shave my head by accident yeah I get I
understand that it is an irrational fear
you probably won't do that but I
completely understand that my irrational
fear is more rational than your both of
yours I'm crazier that's why I'm the
star
you
[Music]